[Musique]
le décor du journal ça vous plaît je
puis vous dire que franchement vous
m'avez bluffé pendant les deux meneurs
vous avoir à compter de choses très
dures mais toujours avec la morosité
c'est à dire le costume parallèle à la
table la coupe qui a été fait par la
clinton changer real c'est le poujadisme
c'était dur d'heure après après rachid
arhab je vous disais qu'elle qui ils
vont nous mettre changements déjà vous
dire cela pourrait que vous allez merci
merci et bravo
jamel debbouze pour votre succès merci
jamel c'est la fin de ce journal tout de
suite la météo patrice drevet attention
donc aux avalanches dans les alpes
20h55 un téléfilm inédit la cliente avec
francis huster et micheline presle 22h35
mots croisés relais de chabot avec
notamment un débat sur l'euthanasie mini
dernier journal jean-claude dont renault
est 6h30 owa voilà dans les 4 vérités
sera françoise laborde avec bernard
debré et on se quitte
regardez encore dernière image queen
mary sa première croisière
la mère s'était calmée à southampton son
port d'attache cap vers la floride
deux mille six cents passagers à bord
deux semaines de voyage merci djamel à
demain
[Musique]